I come to this video playing drop stone
I don't know I never played this guy but
is strong player da david para beyond
peruvian ok from from Russia I guess g3
yeah okay well II five is probably quite
a good move so I'm going to do that
probably transposing to the English
let's see after c4 no so this is just
plain something irregular just
developing stuff here should be good
going for simple solutions quite sure
what why does angling for him this
doesn't seem to be that you wants to
cancel or anything no just plain and
white normal stuff I don't want Bishop
g5 so I'm playing h6 d6 or d 5 i'm
probably both are playable yeah get some
space for the bishop in case of before I
it looks quite that so it looks quite
quite fine for black nothing special but
you we have a good reason and quick
development and no bad piece very quindi
some
Bishop age three
that should be ok if you thinking about
be five maybe this is an idea but it's
nothing special okay I probably have to
take it so Bishop h3 will play play
Bishop h1 I guess
yeah I'm not sure about it maybe this
him to activate the Queen try to trade
his active queen it's not trading I
might go to age five and play for the
activity they're also looking a bitter
they have to square so oh okay that I
didn't expect at all but an interesting
move okay let's just straight should be
okay 97 I guess the the thing that makes
me I mean optimistic is a bit strong a
word but what's that age fall I don't
understand that at all I can go g5 here
right just winning winning a space on
the Queen's on the Kings side I was
thinking that both my bishops are good
on a 7 NH 3 while his bishop on g2 is
not going to do anything great soon so i
would think this should be quite good
what to f5 okay to g6 is probably good
ok so this tried nothing nothing that
worries me too much but ok I understand
that this not much happening probably
quite an equal ish position don't want
to trade it so that the night can come
to f5 it's not not an idea that I like
very much ok so see six or what exactly
ok I'm taking this first I could have
played 66 maybe know that I think of it
hmm yeah that's true I wanted to play
rook f4 but is let c 6
that's a bit annoying actually
yeah really relied on okay forward see
success it's really a problem I don't
know hmm weird I can just take end and
windy 6y stupid stuff okay didn't do it
it didn't do that with just doesn't
which does not mean that this is bad or
anything it was just the other thing was
kind of problematic this might be as
well of course but hi L estimated that
it seems maybe i can simplify a little
bit you don't have a good square of v6
isn't really great
might be five him time morning
wow what did happen in this game I
really don't understand what what went
wrong hmm unless I really have to check
because this was so unassuming what he
played I should really have no problem
whatsoever and still it went down really
quickly so I must have made something
some really really big mistakes
CMC doesn't see a clean technical win
yet on it's probably more than one way
to do it
I don't have much time so night be 5d6
could be one way yeah but it should be
seven I can just really take it on one
on c7 so this is not so convincing I
think
shrine for 97 and 95 winning the pond
check yeah so I somehow got out of this
check check check check bra offered game
drama yet so it's no fun to try to play
this this is nonsense for William on
time and I'm almost totally busted
anyway but what what did happen I mean I
really shouldn't lose this kind of
position here yeah I really I really
shouldn't it looks totally totally fine
what is it what I did it wrong here let
me think about it maybe this was wrong
already I don't know now the c5 c6 is a
is a serious idea it really is maybe a
check if I start like that maybe I'm
preventing this jutsu 93
maybe maybe this is the way to do it
just the way to be more precise what's
this so bad really I mean why might
maybe I'm doing something wrong here did
this is this he could have taken night
at five in the pond you overlooked that
so rookie aid was rubbish anyway so
maybe this him I really felt that this
is somewhat tricky with the porn coming
up but maybe I would have seeing go see
how the computer just says equal maybe
this is the problem that i'm simply over
that i am feared this a little bit too
much and there's nothing nothing that
terrible going on i doesn't look right
though look at this I mean this is a
delicious the draw huh now it's very
difficult i mean even if the computer
says it's a drawing i mean it's not not
so easy to figure out yet it's jack yeah
yeah it all depends on on those little
technical nuances that you have problems
to to figure out if you don't have any
time oops I'm getting getting
counterplay it takes now this is even
quite good because my king is near near
the pawn complicated but in the game we
definitely should have one and one thing
that I definitely have to show this
distance was the simple way to do it
check I had overlooked that he as well
obviously and here yeah I was trying to
trade as much as possible but it's just
it's just lost and then he somehow
stumbled into chi or not not much is
happening here I'm just stopping this
check check check the
this is a draw but Wow tough game thanks
for watching